un órgano que ya pertenece al pasado así
se expresó al presidente tunecino caixes
ayer al anunciar su decisión de disolver
el consejo superior de la magistratura
vamos a trabajar en una ley o decreto
temporal para el consejo superior de la
magistratura y este consejo en sí es una
cosa del pasado a partir de ahora hize
usaid acusa al órgano de corrupción y de
ralentizar los procedimientos en las
investigaciones sobre los asesinatos de
prominentes activistas de izquierda como
el militante suscribe light fallecido en
el 2013
lamentablemente algunos jueces de los
tribunales han manipulado el caso de
hecho criba light no es el primer juicio
en el que se intenta ocultar la verdad
durante años el presidente del consejo
judicial denunció la decisión del jefe
de estado y la tachó de ilegal analistas
políticos afirman por su parte que con
esta resolución caixa side apunta al
partido en nada que ha controlado el
parlamento y varios gobiernos desde la
revolución de 2011 la caída del dictador
ben alí
sayeh tiene en sus manos todo el poder
desde el 25 de julio cuando destituyó a
su primer ministro y suspendió al
parlamento una medida calificada de
golpe de estado por en nada y otros
opositores
algunas figuras políticas y grupos de
derechos humanos han advertido de un
deslizamiento hacia el autoritarismo y
los líderes mundiales han expresado su
preocupación
sin embargo muchos tunecinos acogieron
con satisfacción las medidas del
mandatario contra un sistema político
calificado de corrupto